[Musique]
eric toledano bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté ce vip pour tv 78 on est
au cirano pour une projection toute
particulière qui est celle de votre
dernier film à savoir hors norme
voilà vous êtes leur taille est donc
c'est un lieu que vous connaissez
absolument gérable
je lui ai fait mes arbres on va y
revenir j'étais dans la salle pour
présenter avant de faire une rencontre
et j'ai toujours plaisir à voir
en plus je sais qu'il va y avoir un
grand chamboulement ici puisque we are
mais qui vont refaire donc il ya géant
voir une verrière fois le cinéma demande
en france à issoire maquiller ouais et
où est-ce que c'est ici que vous avez
nourri votre passion du cinéma
ah oui sûrement j'ai vraiment usé les
saillies syrien et tout laisse à halle
en eau la grande salle des petites
salles qui sont autour j'ai vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup fréquenté cinéma c'est
le cinéma de mon enfance et j'ai un
petit relation d'affect parquet hier on
ne faisait partie à quel âge destin mes
parents sont restés moi je suis parti à
peu près après le bac
mais mes parents et en rester là
j'avais une chambre de bonne à paille
mais je n'ai pas beaucoup appareils j'ai
beaucoup à versailles va jusqu'à 25 ans
le 6 ans était et est toujours ici que
ça se passe était de cinéma ouais
seulement la merde dans les oreilles
bien sûr dites moi alors on va parler
d'autres normes on est là pour ça donc
le film stavroguine sortie là on est en
projection spéciale
votre film réalisé comme d'habitude avec
votre binôme et olivier nakache
voilà on le résume en quelques mots vous
faites le fait commentait le second
billet allez-y bah c'est un film qui
raconte l'histoire de deux j'encadre
envahir de patrons d'associations qui
s'occupent des enfants autistes qu'on
appelle des cas sévères c'est à dire des
cas qui n'ont aucune place dans aucune
institution
c'est une histoire vraie qui l'histoire
de deux personnes qui fréquentent depuis
une vingtaine d'années avec olivier et
qui voit là ont décidé en dehors des
règles puisqu'ils ne sont pas
complètement aux normes n'ont pas
d'agrément ministère de la santé
ce culte des cas dont personne ne veut
et pour ce il engage des jeunes des
quartiers difficiles qui sont un peu à
peu des parcours accidentés mais
personne ne veut nous fait donc personne
ne veut non plus d'un côté il y avait un
vrai sujet sur justement de deux forces
on pourrait penser négative ou en tout
cas de personnes sont en situation un
peu de
deux faiblesses qui s'associent pour
créer une dynamique positive
une farce voilà et donc voilà c'est
interprété par d'anciens camps salaires
et zacate voilà alors vincent cassel
bruno lui c'est l'association la boîte
est juste de la voile et juste voilà
dans le film qui est la voie du site
dans les 2 600 membres
et voilà on change toujours un peu et
reda kateb malick c'est l'escale escale
dans le film au logis en sont à changer
la roue de l'association oui mais bon le
principe est le même que j'écris donc
c'est un binôme aussi ils travaillent
ils travaillent en tandem un cancer
depuis longtemps depuis longtemps et
donc le monde de l'association serment
qui vous est cher apparemment vous
connaissez bien comment ça se fait que
vous le monde associatif en général car
mon arme qui nous plaît avec olivier
c'est un mot un endroit où finalement
espèce d'énergie de
de volonté de collectif qui nous
intéresse c'est vrai que c'est un manque
qui nous fascine d'accord et alors ses
deux associés sont là vous les
connaissez particulièrement
oui en fait dans le monde des colos j'ai
rencontré stéphane qui a prêté par
vincent cassel
il ya eu une amitié qui est né et on
sait suivi et nuit qui partit d'écolo et
puis il a eu des enfants autistes
enfin des parents qui ont demandé à
intégrer des enfants autistes
il a dit oui avant d'étudier les cas les
médecins ironique pas le faire il a
quand même fait et finalement ça a eu
des effets sur des enfants qui se sont
socialisés dans un milieu de vie normale
ça crée une vocation chez stéphane et
plus tard il m'a demandé de venir filmer
il m'a dit qu'il paraît que tu veux
faire du cinéma vient filmer ce que je
fais j'ai besoin de montrer pour avoir
des aides relatives des dons c'est un
des premiers films qu'on a fait avec moi
et c'était des professionnels à fait
d'accord et ça nous a jamais lâchés donc
on savait qu'un jour on dansera l'infini
d'accord donc c'est pour ça je vais vous
demander pourquoi les petits cependant
voilà c'est parce que vous preniez il ya
plusieurs paramètres les as a key les
hôtes et quoi alors j'avais dans ma
famille à un enfant autiste de cousins
qui étaient atteints par ce set est avec
autisme essayé c'était quelque chose qui
m'a beaucoup marché français est
toujours aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
toujours proche de lui de sa famille et
j'avais à coeur aussi de décrire le
parcours départ administratif le parking
d'un de souffrances aux belles et très
sainte et la détresse et j'avais envie
de leur rendre hommage
et puis aussi il ya un timing et c'est
vrai que des fois on décide que c'est le
bon moment pour faire un film mais en ce
moment je sens que la société est
bruyante mois yannick énormément way et
c'est pas une intéressante s'intéresser
à ceux qui communiquent différemment
parce que finalement on a classé
l'autisme comme une maladie ça mais ça
ne l'est pas eu il n'accepte pas qu'on
les appelle malades sous différence et
il communique aussi comme maintenant
mais c'est différent ils communiquent ce
que le film raconte pas ça raconte ça et
ça raconte aussi que quand on rentre pas
dans les cases moi c'est un vrai souci
et est ce que c'est le sentiment vous
avez que la société tend de plus en plus
aussi à nous en faire rentrer forcément
dans des cases avec des législations
plus en plus peignez vélo des belges ce
que je fais il ya d'abord les cas ne
peut pas tout ça n'agit que raconte le
film via des interstices elle déniche
dans lesquelles il peut pas aller et
dans lesquels parfois les associations
finalement pour le travail de l'état et
s'est cassé ce qu'on raconte
et après il faut le temps que l'état se
rendent tous tu viens faire un travail
qui ne faut et les cas sévères ont-ils
c'est un cas dramatiques catherine
mouchet qui joue le médecin enfin élise
ils le disent c'est paradoxal que vous
n'êtes pas cas complexes - vous êtes
pris en charge
ça n'a pas d'équivalent il n'y a pas de
classe il ya pas de procession une
solution n'y a pas de solution donc
c'est vrai que ce film raconte aussi la
place qu'on n'a pas quand on est jeunes
déscolarisés la place qu'on n'a pas
quand on est autiste cas sévères donc
est-ce que ça crée aussi comme énergie
c'est ça que je veux dire parce que
finalement dans ces associations tout le
monde travaille ensemble quelles que
soient les différences pour ces enfants
qui sont vulnérables tout le monde
travaille ensemble comme vous dites on
voit bien que l'association la voix des
justes et une association juive mais que
l'association l'escale est une
association musulmane alors quelle
solution sepa vaut mieux c'est à dire
elle est dirigée par deux personnes ont
ils ajouté juste après ce qui était
intéressant dans ce film c'est qu'aucun
des deux n'a j entends que mais jamais
il fut musulmans mais a trahi qu'ils
acceptent des enfants évidemment de
toutes origines comme les respectables
quand quelqu'un est en souffrance on lui
demande pas de quel pays il vient ni de
quelle religion il est et c'est ça aussi
qui nous a aimés avec olivier c'est qu'à
un moment ce n'est que dans ces espaces
là que les antagonismes et les tensions
disparaissent et donc il ya une forme
d'intelligence supérieure là bas où il
n'y a plus de le bien commun et pour le
même but
je crois que ça rassure un peu surtout
dans des périodes de pointe wilson se
passe très bien et finalement on s'en
fout pas la religion parce quelque chose
de plus important qu'il ya un lobby juif
aurait là dessus et donc c'est peut-être
un modèle intéressant à étudier sont à
éviter mais avec avec un vague arrive
après les regards alors comment vous
avez définissent ce duo vincent cassel
reda kateb comment il est pas alors là
pour le coup là on vous quitte le monde
associatif est allé au cinéma et c'est
non et c'est bien mais c'est vraiment
parti de cinématographique c'est à dire
par une envie de cinéma de voir ce jeu à
l'écran deux acteurs incroyables qu'on
adore et qu'on voulait réunir
on avait un d'abord ça serait bien qu à
celle qu'a ted et ensuite ces deux
monstres du cinéma français du coup on a
fait une expérience assez original on
n'avait pas de scénario au moment où les
a contactés la wii donc on leur a dit
venez deux heures dans chacune des
associations et dit tout ça vous
intéresse qu'on écrive ce film pour vous
et c'est ce qui s'est passé oui cela
veut dire non et on l'a jamais sciemment
ou non non répond hollande n'aurait pas
voulu mais non voyons dit oui et c'est
ça que je trouve
et évidemment ce sont d'excellents
acteurs ils sont impliqués mais on est
absolue qu'il ya un truc en plus quand
même qui les portent dans ce rôle et que
que ça va plus loin
est-ce qu'en plus ils ont travaillé par
vous avez tous travaillé avec des vrais
des vraies personnes atteintes d'autisme
avec des vrais jeunes de banlieue
peut-être aussi qu'il n'était pas acteur
d'éducateurs oui et voilà ambiance
particulière parce que c'est un film on
pouvait pas le faire en arrivant la
veille d'un autre pays
j'ai un tournage en disant je vais façon
il fallait forcément passer par un temps
d'adaptation anthony version que les
enfants s'habituent à cellules aux
éducateurs mais oui parce que c'est pas
évident donc il a fallu beaucoup
d'humilité pour aller passer des
journées préparation il faut certaines
qualités humaines j'imagine pour il faut
que ça il faut que ça match et puis
comme dit vincent dans les interviews au
début
il a été bouleversé comme beaucoup il a
été il a été ému parfois même aux larmes
en six ans comment je vais faire c'est
qu'après passé ce première étape de
compassion il a vu les autres
travaillent il s'est mis comme un
caméléon à observer et puis il a
répliqué il a fait il a interprété le
rôle et du coup ils la qualité vient
aussi du fait qu'ils y ont passé du
temps ça se ressent vraiment et
finalement c'est tout c'est tous ces
personnages convoi ils sont tous hors
norme à leur façon tout ce que voilà les
seules compris mal mais autistes madame
en y laissant les jeunes ont évidemment
et au final l'administration se fait
gagner parce hors norme puisque au lieu
de fermer l'association et je ne suis
pas une pas la fin mais effectivement il
ya un moment où il ya une phrase qui va
marquer pendant qu'on prépare et de
films qui parlent en film qui nécessité
fait loi
parfois quand on pallie à une société
d'urgence dans la société justement
bah là ça passe au dessus de l'amour et
oui parce que ce qu'on dit pas c'est que
dans le film iranien
un autre duo de d'inspecteurs du
ministère de la santé j'imagine qu'ils
viennent un petit peu mettre leur nez
pour vérifier le sait on suit parce que
c'est un qui nous amène à traverser le
film et à comprendre les enjeux
qui sont là les parents c'est une
inspection de l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales
voilà c'est ça qui me guide un peu le
sénateur john kyl notre image du film
est là vous avez vous présenter le film
dans de nombreuses villes de province
oui alors les réactions du public 1
d'abord il ya eu la première projection
qui était folle c'est calme parce que
c'est déjà génial et à cannes c'est la
clôture du festival
ça a été le lancement est donc voila a
été dans une trentaine de villes
écoutez c'est ce sont des réactions très
très forte le film mais fort bien
l'effort donc les débats étaient
toujours assez puissant je dis souvent
je suivante on a fait beaucoup de
comédies ce soit le sens de la fête
intouchable nos jours heureux tellement
preuves mais on avait l'habitude de
rentrer dans les salles comme une petite
souris puis d'écouter les rires
l'armée entend les rires il y en a
beaucoup gênés beaucoup aussi mais on
entend quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas
entendu dans les dernières moment dans
les derniers moments du film les espèces
de silence qui nous qui nous touche
énormément et qui est cette forme de
communication
d'ailleurs c'est un hasard mais la vraie
association s'appelle le silence des
justes et ceci dans ce cas on l'entend
comme si on avait capté l'attention dans
une société encore une fois bruyante et
connecté yt c'est un manga à un moment
où voilà les gens ne reprenne pas tout
de suite leur portable ni leur congrès
sur une interface à base de chape de
plomb est dans la salle et je pense que
le sujet mérite mais sur plus que nous
et notre film léger les soignants qui
ont vu le film qui vous disent sur les
premiers spectateurs qu'on a vu de loin
les infirmières des éducateurs les
médecins des pédopsychiatres les parents
se sont exprimées au premier voir
comment les avaient représenté
écoutez c'était magnifique je pense
qu'ils se sentent leur voix un peu plus
écoutés ils sortent un peu plus
d'attention sur monde d'accord et s'il y
avait une personne qui devrait avoir ce
film qui vous auriez envie de montrer ce
film en particulier à part évidemment
tourner tout le public alors il ya eu
une projection à l'assemblée nationale y
apprit quinzaine de jours devant la
secrétaire d'état sophie cluzel
soc 20 d'état aux handicapés à
l'exclusion bien plusieurs députés
j'aurais envie peut-être de façon ultime
que le président de la république où
elle film puisque je sais que sa femme
brigitte macron est très sensible elle
est très présente sur l'autisme en
france
marraine de pas mal d'associations donc
j'aimerais que tous les décideurs et
tous ceux qui votent les lois soient au
courant que l'on ne peut pas laisser au
ban de la société
une partie de la population parce que
c'est la pelure elle est violente qu'il
faut le dire allez parfois agressive
elle est parfois incompréhensibles à nos
yeux
pour autant ces associations en montre
que toute personne est humaine et que
quand elle arrive sur cette planète
au milieu de nous on a toujours deux
choix soit l'éloigner de notre regard
soit l'inclure et que en un plus en
pratiquant l'inclusion
il y a des vrais progrès en seraient
atteintes au col il ya des vrais progrès
il ya des violences qui s'apaise il ya
des enfants et des adolescents des
adultes qui progresse et qui finalement
trouvent leur place trouvent du boulot
c'est ce que raconte le film d'ailleurs
joseph baptiste un autiste qui a joué
dans le film
donc il ya tout un tas de possibilités
qui s'offrent et tout un tas de modèles
qui peuvent être pris en exemple donc
c'est un film un peu plus engagés que
les autres et on reviendra peut-être pas
une comédie plus pu réagir celui-là est
élevé s'explique il existe positionner
vraiment un hockey m'a écouté un grand
merci parce que c'est un film très fort
très beau merci qui quid du bien qui
fait réfléchir puisque pas de mal un
fichier un tisseur et puis toujours très
heureux de revenir
merci c'est dj mattawa natale pour
revenir mais dans cette ambiance du
marché du cerrado et et de droite de
versailles
[Musique]